anybody familiar with this term double
check in chest raise your hand if you
know what's double check okay yes
what's double check okay it's when you
making a move and checking opponents
kink with two pieces at the same time
very good and normally when you do that
if the king is under the check he has to
move somewhere if the King cannot go
anywhere it's going to be a checkmate
okay because you cannot block two tricks
in one move or you cannot capture two
pieces in one move so that's why double
check is a very strong tactical idea if
you get a chance you always have to look
for double tricks sometimes it's not
there like in this particular example I
set up for your here there is no double
check immediately but you need to think
and create one okay so in this position
white is going to be able to win in
three moves mate in three white to play
mate in three and the team would be a
double check idea okay and I want you to
spend some time and raise your hand if
you see it okay but let's let's spend a
little bit of time here to see how we
can try to come up with the double check
idea and checkmate in three moves again
double check is a very strong tactical
idea that you should definitely know
okay let's see look at the king the king
so the king is the target here right
this King this week so what can we try
to do so we can set up a mating idea yes
okay but to how you want to do that
which was the first move move the rook
up to one square or here okay let's say
you move the rook up now you're
threatening to bring the Queen here and
checkmate because you opened up very
good is you see that then you have a
bishop and queen when you have a bishop
when you have bishop and queen on the
same diagon what we call that what we
call when you have a bishop and queen on
the same diagonal yes
battery excellent so remember bishop and
queen on the same diagram that's a
battery it's a very strong battery yes
you have a question
well are you trying to move the rook
here yeah but the year when you make a
move I'm gonna make a move for black too
right so remember it you make one move I
make one move so first it's very
important to recognize what we have here
right yeah so we recognize what we have
in this position so we have a potential
battery here - okay
so how can we do that here to set up the
checkmate so who can tell me the first
move here the move you suggested loop
going back it's an okay move but see I
can push my pawn and block it and I will
block the diagonal okay so that's why
you need to do something with a check
okay you need to do something with a
check to be able to find and checkmate
in three moves and the idea is double
check idea yes gg7 Queen to g7 but but
if you go here right do you see that the
rock is blocking the bishop so I
actually can take see if the rook wasn't
there that would it will check me so but
we have a strong idea on this diagonal
see when the bishop and Queen on the
same diagonal again so a lot of people
just came in it's called a battery okay
when you have a bishop and queen on same
diagonal raise your hand if you see the
mate in three now let's say this is a
very exciting position okay just just
just raise your hand yeah don't need to
make any noise here just raise your hand
okay
only one okay okay - okay good good very
good let's see okay what's the first
move just the first move what do you
think aha yes very good Queen a changes
sacrificing the Queen and for a moment
it looks like must be a blunder because
black King just can't take it right
nothing is really protecting it but now
the king is going to be on the same
diagonal as the bishop now comes the
double check
do you see the double check now yes try
try to see the square see we have the
letters here H that will be H and the
numbers right try to try to try to say
the square root H to check is it just a
check or double check where it's not
double check when it's not immediate see
see this was the example I was telling
you that when you check with two pieces
at the same time he has to move the King
for example if black rook was here on g8
this would have been what checkmate
right because the King cannot go there
now he has to go here and now let's see
how many people see the checkmate in one
move now
yes okay this is the rope right rook and
what square is this here which file is
this look at here
now it's agent 3h route h8 okay
checkmate
okay very good very good yes okay so did
everybody see this one okay let's do it
again let's do it again this is very
important because you can win a lot of
games if you know this double check idea
and here we don't have it right away but
we have to sacrifice the Queen the most
valuable piece to create the double
check and then the mate okay let's go
over this one more time what's the first
move okay let's see yes
go into H a check has to take it and now
follow it up yes Rock - H - double check
right and when there is a double check
remember King has to go somewhere
because he cannot just block two checks
in one move or capture - piece in one
move has to go summary the King has no
squares to go - means it's a checkmate
so now King has to go to g8 and see the
mate yes rook to h8 checkmate okay
excellent very good okay now let's take
a look at this position it looks like
white plate made several mistakes now
because he's down the rook and a bishop
at least okay let's just yeah just raise
your hand remember just raise your hand
if you see the mate
so again white is down a rope and a
bishop but it's white to play and you
can use the idea I told you about double
check and find the checkmate here again
in three moves so let's spend a little
bit of time that everybody will think
and try to find also okay always look at
the opponent King where is the black
King and what can you do here
it's made in 3y2 Plame 18:3 okay we have
a lot of hands that's good let's see you
see - okay good you see - okay excellent
okay all right let's see okay you you
want to try no not ready okay let's see
yes
aha Bishop to g5 it's a it's a pretty
good move and you are creating a threat
of Queen d8 made right by the thing is
he's gonna move and block it okay so
that's why we don't have time we have to
make a move that is going to be a check
okay because otherwise he's going to
move the bishop and block it okay so
let's see here what can we do look at
the Kings now okay
yes in the back Queen da check now again
it looks like you can just take the
Queen right nothing is really protecting
it now he takes the Queen and now what
are you gonna do you need to follow it
up here precisely because the King is on
the same line as the rook and official
yes aha Bishop to g5 check with the
bishop and check with the rook right
it's a double check again when there is
a double check king has to go somewhere
if you cannot go anywhere again it's
going to be a mate
so King has to go to e8 and now let's
see the checkmate yes rook rook to the a
checkmate alright let's go back and see
this this is a real position from a real
game actually we can have this kind of
position if you know this idea sacrifice
the Queen and then follow it up with a
double check okay so remember that so
again let's go over this one more time
Queen da check King has to take no
choice now Bishop to g5 check
King goes back to the 8th and rook e8
mate now same the similar position I'm
going to change the position a little
bit okay a little bit so you can see if
you can find it here let's see just a
little bit I change the position now
let's see if you can find a checkmate in
three again the same idea doesn't work
because the pawn only 7 is already
blocking this diagonal so now you have
to do it different but since you know
the idea I think it will be easy for you
to find this one too okay just this
guy's they just just raise your hand
okay just I can see your hand perfect
okay let's see it's similar it's similar
to the previous is just a little bit
different because the pawn only 7 again
this pawn is blocking this diagonal so
if you go there with the bishop it's not
going to be a double check you have to
use a double check idea here find the
checkmate let's see yes Queen da check
again now has to take it now look at the
King what can you do now yes okay all
right okay you will find the next one
okay Bishop a5 check now check with the
bishop and with the rook again double
check right King has to go to e8 only
move and now what do you do to find a
mate yes okay there you go
look to d8 mate okay you see this idea
okay very good
so it's very similar but you have to and
you have a bishop you have to look
because the bishop can go both ways can
go to 85 and then can go to g5 here too
so again we start with clean da check
and if it takes Bishop a5 check King
only a
interrupting me okay now in this
position white white is down night and
two pounds so it's down lots of material
but now you have to make sure you find a
way to it's a checkmate in two moves
this one into this is checkmate in two
okay okay let's let's think about it for
a little bit again you have to look at
your bishop when you have to look at
your bishop here because the bishop is a
very important piece it's white to play
again don't rush think
okay good it has to be a trick it has to
be a check remember the first one has to
be a check okay and kind of shake shake
aha see he's saying rook c8 which is a
it's a good move but it's not a check
right that gives me time to think of a
defense for example I may go here and
say check to you now see sorry so it's
not so clear so you have to look for the
check first move has to be a check okay
yes Queen to g7 sacrificing the Queen
Sookie has to take it no choice right
King takes and now now discovery double
checkmate let's see it's also discovery
idea now yes
aha rook to g3 you check with the bishop
and the rock King cannot go anywhere
it's a discovery double checkmate if the
night wasn't on h6 then he could escape
but here he cannot go anywhere okay so
let's do this again this idea so we
start with Queen g7 check he has to take
it and then you move the rope to g3 and
mate okay okay next position okay let's
take a look at this position if it's
blocked to play he's going to just take
this pawn and checkmate in one move okay
so that's why you have to be very
careful if you make a move that is not
check then he's going to take on g2 and
it's going to be a mate okay so that's
why you don't want to rush here so think
about an idea that you can do it's a
checkmate in three moves again it's
three moves now we're back to three move
checkmates now again using the double
check idea but we don't have it here we
need to create one okay that's what you
need to do here you need to create the
double check and then follow it up with
a checkmate
okay just raise your hand let's see
let's give a little bit more time let's
give a little bit more time so everyone
can think they have time to think and
try to find it so think of idea now
where can you force the black King to go
to here so you have a double check idea
where can you force the king okay
okay okay yes first of all give us the
first note point 2f h @c did you see
this move it's a long range move that's
five when you play chess you always have
to look at the entire board because
sometimes you're good movies from one
side to the other side of the board you
can just focus on one area thinking you
have something on a king side or Queens
that you have to look at the whole 64
squares and to find this kind of move
it's a long-range move you go Queen FA
check now that's black have any options
except taking the Queen any options no
has to take it now you successfully
force this King on the same line where
your rook and Bishop is now what are you
going to do
and by the way normally when you do a
double check it involves another idea
called discovery okay discovery you have
to you can't just it's a discovery move
to to do the double check now you see
the double check yes it has to check the
king to D D 6 D 6 all right very good
Bishop d6 now check did everyone see now
it's a double check idea again right so
but the King has a score to go to so
that's why it's not a checkmate yet he's
going to go to e8 and now and this
already is similar to the previous
positions they did now checkmate in one
let's see okay yes yeah
broke to f8 checkmate again okay so do
you see in this examples it shows how
strong double check can be it's a very
strong idea double check and again if
you have one you go like we did one like
before this it was a right there we
sacrifice and here you sacrifice the
Queen to force the King to go there and
then we go with the bishop check has to
go to E and then checkmate
okay now I have another position for you
here okay
the next position we have here it's
white to play checkmate in three let's
think about it a little bit first and
then raise your hand think about it
first it's white to play checkmate in
three again we're still on the same
topic discovery double check it's three
moves okay let don't rush check double
check your answer so let's give a minute
or two so everyone can think and raise
your hand you know even if you're not
100% sure it's okay just raise your hand
and give it a try okay because you get a
lot better by actually finding this
moves even sometimes it's not correct
it's okay
so one thing you have to realize here we
have a bishop and a queen on the same
diagonal again what we call that when we
have a bishop and Queen on the same
diagonal parry
okay battery okay so there is a
potential strong battery on this
diagonal but we need to find a way to
weaken the position of the King okay and
I need you the reason we're doing this
so you can recognize these patterns okay
in your games when you have it you
should do a lot of disposition so when
you actually have in your game you can
see it because now when I'm setting it
up you already know that there is
something but when you
your games no one is going to tell you
that there is something there so you
should actually feel it that there is
something and then you will find a
solution here so let's see mate in three
using the discovery ideas okay the first
look is very important because if you
don't find the first move then it's
going to be a problem and by the way if
you look at the material who has more
material in this position black right
black has two rooks why doesn't have
even one so if let's say the Queen's
come off the board and game is going to
be easily won for black so you you can't
do that
you have to find something very strong
here so let's see now yes in the back
you could move the bishop on a four but
do you see that he wants to take your
queen you're going to take his queen but
you're going to lose your queen and then
you cannot check me first move has to be
a check remember these positions I'm
sending out the first move has to be a
check because otherwise black is going
to have time to defend so you have to
look for the check first move yes yes
excellent
Queen to f6 check now he takes like
right now it's just a check right now he
takes the bishop now don't rush you have
two different double checks and that's
why this is a little bit tricky you have
two different double checks which one is
the best if you play the wrong one
you're not going to be able to checkmate
if you play the correct one you're going
to be able to do checkmate in two moves
again you have two different double
checks you have two different ones and
it's always tricky inches oftentimes we
make a mistake when there are too many
good possibilities and you choose the
wrong ones okay let's see let's see who
wants to give try they're two of them
which one is the best yes
- excellent 924 C there are options to
go with 95 - but if you go night defy
you're going to allow the King to escape
on g5 and then it's going to be much
harder to win you might still be able to
do it but it's not going to be that
clear that's why I was saying check your
answer right I say check your answer
because it's a trick here because there
are too many of them so 94 was excellent
now it's a double check what's the only
move here for black what's the only move
here for black to go to to avoid yes
eise evan eise evan King to East 7 only
move and now time to checkmate
yes yeah excellent bishop goes to f6 and
the plot king is checkmated actually
it's kind of like a smother mate idea
because the squares the rooks are
guarding his own pieces are blocking the
King to go to and now he can't go
anywhere you have a question yeah now I
was thinking there was no no okay okay
and now it's a maze King has not
supposed to go to okay so let's do this
again one more time this is a little
trickier okay then the other ones
because it's said you have option to go
wrong you have two of them two checks
okay how do we start here the first move
what was the first move here remember
yes
Quinn takes f6 check now
we also going to look at the
possibilities if if it doesn't take if
he goes here
who can show me the checkmate in one
move one move one move only one move
it's going to be a checkmate now yes
excellency you also look at the moves
going back not always you look at the
moves going forward you also look at the
moves that are going back sometimes the
strongroom is the move that you go back
and now you go Bishop c1 and now
checkmate
can do anything excellent and if he goes
here now how can you win this game here
what you need to do here to be able to
checkmate here look at these dark
squares right you want to find a way to
checkmate iam on g7 or h8 but what you
need to do in order to be able to do
that yes
you forgot okay it's okay yes you want
to do that but you can do right away
because the knight is blocked okay what
can you do with this knight first think
of doing something with this knight
first and then Queen g7 or 188 will be
unstoppable checkmate yes 99 to d5 and
now he takes and then we can choose from
where we want to check mate from g7 or
from HH no difference okay so again we
start out with Queen f6 check King goes
if he goes to HHH six we do a checkpoint
from c1 very important to see the moves
going back to okay and now if he goes to
g8 we take the pawn open up the diagonal
and checkmate now and if it takes and
this is a tricky part because you had
two different ways to do a double check
it's very easy it's possible to go wrong
catch it's possible to go wrong here so
which one is the best here which move
yes check we take away the g5 squared so
he cannot go anywhere taken taken taken
so has to go back only seven only move
and now time to checkmate right raise
your hand if you see the checkmate now
you should see the mate now how can you
check your skin to say checkmate yes
which piece is going to checkmate huh
look at the King Bishop here
that's Bishop right and that's F file we
say Bishop F and that's the six strand
right so that will be Bishop f6
checkmate
all right okay good all right very good
we continue we continue on this topic
here okay
this is a different idea than the
previous ones okay this is a little bit
different
okay let's see he's got so many extra
pieces so you have to find a way to
check right think think about it okay
yes you could do that but the thing is
you have to do make a movie to check
yeah because you know black black is
threatening check YouTube okay check
from here so if you make a rock move
we're not checking him that that's will
allow him to make a move so you need to
find a way to check him okay the first
one has to be a check first one has to
be a check Queen takes h7 excellent
again it's a sacrifice sacrifice of the
Queen now he has to take it no choice
King takes h7 now now with what more we
need here what moving it here yes
double check rook to h2 move the rook
double check check with the bishop and
check with the rook right all the option
is to move back and once the king is
moving back now what do we do to find
the checkmate yes absolutely
checkmate okay because the king is
trapped again trapped by his own pieces
it's kind of a smother mate idea okay
how many of you know the smother mate
idea okay so we will do this mother made
next okay because I think it will be
very useful to know this one okay white
to play again it involves a double check
idea white to play checkmate in three
okay
okay this is called smother maid okay
you will see at the end of the line why
is it called smother maid okay because
blocking is going to be smothered by his
own pieces pawns and rook and then
you're going to be able to check me
okay everyone everyone should be looking
at the screen okay
and try to find the checkmate in to
remove that involves the double check
now right away double check needed right
away the next one should be double check
to start the combination yes excellent 9
to h6 double check if the King could
didn't have the square to go to this
would have been a maid already so but he
has a square to go to to h8 it's a check
with the queen and with at night and now
ok just raise your hand that's good ok
now what's the move here this is really
the hard movies right here because you
need to set up the checkmate yes Queen
to g8 sacrificing the Queen now King
cannot capture because the knight is
protecting it so he has to take with the
rook which is the only when I look at
this King kind of smothered right it
looks smothered so now what do you do
you can win so many games like this in a
blitz games especially in this
combination you can do it now what's the
next move now let's see yes huh
f71 night-night
there you go night f7 checkmate look at
that
can't go anywhere can go here Lucas
taking the square and the pawns are
blocking this is the smother made so if
you heard that name smother made means
this position this is the this it this
is how it looks like the smother made
okay
King is smothered and cannot go anywhere
let's go back and do this again that's a
very common idea a lot of Grandmaster
games when they play against each other
this is always seen this tactical idea
so we try to prevent this and you know
if you're trying to attack with trying
to do this so let's see again why to
play mate in three raise your hand yes
first move
double check has to go to h8 and now
next move very good go into GA check
can't take it 90s garden so has to take
with the rook and now the King is
smothered we always remember this
position where the King is smothered
like this okay and then you use the
knight that's why they say Knight is a
very tricky piece see if you had a
bishop or OOP you couldn't check in this
position but I'm only with a knight you
can check here that's why the knight is
very strong piece and what do you do to
checkmate
- okay only with the night if you had
any other piece you couldn't do a
checkmate in this position only with the
night we can do that okay okay the King
component game it seems like it should
be easy to play King and pawn Aeneas
because not that many pieces on the
board but you will be surprised so many
tricks that you need to know about these
positions so I have a question for you
if it's white to play is this a win or a
job if it's white to play it's very
important in these positions whose move
is it so if it's white to play it's a
win or a draw win okay let's see raise
your hand if you think it's a win with
white to play it's a win raise your hand
aha not so sure you all right okay so
it's a win okay raise your hand if you
think it's a draw with white to move
uh-huh okay we have more hands so in
fact it's a little bit strange but in
this particular position if it's your
move to make it's a disadvantage normal
interests if we get a move that's an
advantage to have but in this position
is a disadvantage because in this
position when the Kings are in front of
each other what is the core we call this
when the Kings in front of each other's
opposition not top position yeah okay so
it's an opposition and whichever side is
going to move here white or black they
will lose the opposition our position is
a key here to make a draw for the player
down upon it's a key to make a draw and
a player who is a Papon is a way to win
the game so if it's a white to play this
position is a draw if it's a block to
play it's a win for white now we will
see the both scenarios here
so first if it's white to play you move
the King now what's the move to make a
draw here to get our position again yes
absolutely
now I want to move that this black has
the opposition if it goes back we go
back nothing will be happening so it
will repeat eventually he will start
pushing the pawn the only way to win
this position is you have to get your
king in front of the pond if you cannot
do that it's going to be a draw and here
as you can see white cannot get the King
in front of the pawn and now what are
you going to play here for black to make
a draw again if you go wrong you can
lose this position that's why you must
know how to play these positions for
both sides what's the move here here now
this six is here you can come here eat
seven you go here in front of the pawn
okay you go in front of the pawn this is
very important now why there is no
options he is going to push the pawn
he's six now if you have actually four
different moves here for black three all
the moves you make you're going to lose
only one move is going to make a draw
here do you know the correct move here
raise your hand if you know this
position or you've studied before it's
one of the most important King and pawn
endgame positions you know this position
the mouse will become always down there
without lost with it but I'm trying to
correct moves but you can go straight
back huh
now correct movies King II a okay right
right there see this course I'm
highlighting you go here you're going to
lose the game see all the squares see go
you're going to lose again because if
you go here he will just go here and
then you're not blocking the pawn
anymore he just potion Queen if you go
here now he's going to step up and it's
black to move that means who has that
position white has that position he has
to move you push the pawn he's going to
get out you come forward and you Quinn
same thing is going to happen here
because if you go here you're going to
step up and what kind of opposition is
this do you know what kind of opposition
is this diagonal diagonal opposition
okay because on a diagonal now he comes
up your push is going to get out and you
Quinn and you win the game so you have
to play King it always remember at the
final stage here you go back facing the
pawn okay because now if it comes up
what do you do can take it
opposition right yes
now he pushes the pond check you go back
here now if it goes away from the pond
you can just capture the pond and if it
goes to e6 or what is this still mate
okay remember Steam and everybody know
what's still made everybody should know
what's still made yes
so from within position first started
when you first set it up there is no way
for white and get the economy from there
know if it's white to play not if it's
black to play we get a look at up now if
it's a black to play it's a win if it's
a white to play it's a draw okay yeah
but that's a little bit different well
that's what we'll talk about that later
that's different position a little bit
but again I just want to kind of go over
the steel made idea because I want to
make sure everybody knows the steel made
still made is basically for black is now
still mated because he's not under a
check okay but he doesn't have any other
legal moves to make so any move he makes
is going to be illegal now like he can
go here right there we legal pawn his
guarding it and kink and he can't go
here King is gone so it's a stalemate
means a draw because black doesn't have
any legal moves to make and you can make
an illegal move okay
so that's fine now so let's do this
again I will play this for white and you
play us black let's see if you can play
the good defense and make a draw here
what's the correct move for black now I
will play for the white side you play as
a black as black here yes now we repeat
I push now what's next what do you what
do you do here
where do you go now here where you can
go wrong see a lot of people get to this
position and then they don't know the
best defense here and if you don't know
the defense or you try to guess most
likely going to go wrong and lose
because as I mentioned see this
highlighted squares you go to any of the
squares you lose the game
see it's easy to go wrong three three
three different squares you go to you
lose only one you draw so what's the
correct move here to make a draw
remember what's the correct move yes
excellent you face the pond yeah very
good go in front of the pond now he goes
here continue you need to get the
opposition right Kings in front of each
other
we call that an opposition yes huh da I
have to push no choice now of course you
have to block the pawn and if it goes
here and everyone should know what we
call this position draw because of you
mate still mate remember that okay it's
still me now we go back to the same
position and we're going to make this
position black to move and we're going
to see why this position is winning now
if it's a black to move that means he
has to move the King and means you have
the opposition so let's say he moves
here you go to f6 it goes back here
again here you can make a wrong move and
it's going to be a draw you go back and
you get the opposition okay you're on
Russia advancing the pawn you go back
and you get the opposition again now he
goes to d8 or f8 and what's the winning
move now everyone should be watching the
screen it's very important okay this
position there everyone should be
watching so they know what to do in
these positions okay how they can win
this
so King to d7 and now king f7 and you
can do anything to stop this pawn you
push push and do you know how to check
mate with the Queen yes everyone knows
okay so okay I will show you how to do
it okay basically the way you want to
checkmate here you want to make sure you
don't give any checks you're only going
to give check one time at the end of the
game when you say checkmate so remember
that you don't give any checks until the
last move okay so I'll show you the most
effective way how to check how to drag
opponent King to the corner and
checkmate so you make a move
now he comes up and you always take the
square the opponent King was there the
previous care opponent King was there so
you come up you come up you take the
square that he was previously without
checking okay now if it goes here you
step here cut cut the King now so he
can't go to the F file anymore because
here take the square again cut see it
ventually it looks like a big board but
eventually it's going to run out of
squares so you step up now do you want
to put the Queen here if you put the
Queen here actually a lot of people do
this
they play quickly quickly they move and
then it then they make another quick
move and then still make draw okay so
you have to make sure you leave your
opponent de square so you can go back
and forth back and forth okay so you
will still make and now I actually still
mated somebody when I just start playing
chess and I I didn't know this stalemate
idea and I was winning and I still made
somebody like this so you go up now you
want to bring your king to f3
and when the king is on after he goes
here and what's the mate checkmate in
one move
excellent okay so remember when you get
a queen which is the king I see a lot of
people day they know it's a week but
they don't know exactly how to do it and
they just start checking when you start
shaking the king it's not going to be
effective
let's say you don't give any checks you
drive the King to the corner by taking
all the squares and at the end at the
very end you do checkmate and you have
to make sure you don't still mate okay
so it's very important when you do this
idea you don't accidentally go here
thinking that you take away squares
because eventually now no more squares
it's going to be a stalemate
okay all right let's go over this one
more time to see how you win this
position okay so black goes here let's
see if you can win this for white now
what's the best move here for white to
advance the phone right remember you to
advance the pawn what do you do now
let's see what's the move here see yes
no if you go King the fact that he goes
back he just goes back here so okay so
see that's why you have to be very
paying attention close attention so you
can see how to win this he steps away
now I get your King ahead yes
very good now he goes back here now if
you go wrong here it's going to be a
draw and what's the winning move here
what's the winning move here now you
don't want to allow the opposition
what's the move here we want to get the
opposition one more time because if we
push the pot here it's going to be a
draw
he's going to go here and get that
position so you want to get that
position yes go ahead ha ha now you get
the opposition again now he has to step
away this way or that way doesn't matter
let's say he goes this way now where do
we go with the king so we can promote
out upon into a queen yes F ff7 right F
7 e7 is here so he goes here and now he
cannot stop your pawn anymore from
promoting into a queen so you go here
push and let's do one more time how do
we do the checkmate here let's say he
goes here now I want you to do it
precisely the way I told you to do it
okay we're now giving any checks drive
the King to the corner who wants to go
first yes okay next
six very good yes b5 now go Sarah
continue no checks right very good
now he goes to other file you go that
way too
I mean if you go to either it will be a
check remember we don't want to check we
only check one time at the end of the
game when we say checkmate no need to
check here yes
again you cut the Kings the square so
you can go to he goes here continue now
what do you do now remember yes now be
be fine
now it goes here see this is the most
effective way to trap me with a queen
and king and now yes now it was a very
important move here what's the move here
remember because if you go wrong here
it's going to be a stalemate yes no no
this is b1 you don't want to go here
right and remember the trick right if
you go here still me so right here you
stop you want to leave the King asked
where to go to okay you want to leave
this square so you can go back and forth
back and forth and now you want to bring
your King right here I need you to bring
the King right there - checkmate okay
that's what you got to do okay now go
ahead bring the King yes
very good now he goes here continue
just bring the king that's all what you
gotta do here bring the king now it goes
here yes see for you this is b3 you can
go here yet right so you get closer by
going here now goes here and now one
more movie the king we need one more
move right excellent and now once the
King is already on c3 it's time to
checkmate and now what's the last move
here yes you yeah Queen B - checkmate
okay very good okay so that's how you
check me so again very important to
remember when you see this king of
compositions
don't just think one side is winning
because of the extra pawn try to first
see whose move is it and in true it's
very important to know whose move is it
okay yes so is it bad okay half the way
we can I think I learned when the black
King we start the opposition yes is this
when the black king is only seven right
no no opposition is just the Kings are
in front of each other once Queen
separates them that's opposition okay
when the Kings are in 4e King start in
front of you try that that's the
opposition if it's only one square
separating so it's very it's important
to whose move is it okay it's important
whose move is it if it's white to move
we saw that it's a draw
it's a disadvantage to have the move
actually here so if it's a block to move
again the disadvantage for black in that
case he loses so even
working steps back nah IQ if you step
back what you lose now it will be a draw
it would be a drop so if it's white to
move it slow regardless already okay and
if it's a black move a black to move you
moves away and you activate your king
okay okay I recommend practicing these
positions okay against a friend or
somebody just set up this position and
practice more you play this position you
will understand even better okay so
remember it's a disadvantage for the
side to move here okay if it's white
it's a draw because you lose the
opposition if it's black to move then
white wins because he's going to be able
to promote and always remember to
double-check ideas okay we did a lot of
them today the double check ideas it's a
very strong tactical idea when you do a
double check opponent has to move the
King because he can block two checks in
one move okay okay everyone good job
okay
you